es ist rätselhaft was im universum vor
sich geht unsere galaxie wird zu einem
roten attraktor im universum gestoßen
und nicht nur angezogen wie wird von
einer bis dato unbekannten instanz in
richtung dieses große attraktor mertes
mehr darüber bekannt und was es damit
auf sich hat dafür taktik 51 ticks
der rote attraktor ist eines der
grössten rät wenn es um die bewegung im
universum geht es handelt sich hierbei
um einen filament also so bezeichnet man
die galaxienhaufen und die fäden die
gasförmigen die sie miteinander
verbinden
seit 1970 ern weiß man von diesem thema
praktisch und eigentlich den sicher das
universum seit dem urknall und auch
völlig aus aber trotzdem ziehen sich die
galaxien und galaxienhaufen gegenseitig
an forschungs ergebnisse besagen dass
unsere milchstraße auf diesen großen
attraktor zusteuerten an führungskraft
ist nämlich so hoch dass ganze galaxien
von ihm angezogen werden er besteht aus
dem norma hydra und centaurus haufen und
darauf wie wichtig unsere milchstraße zu
moment mal wir steuern auf einen sternen
schwingertag und zwar mit 2 millionen
kilometern pro stunde
der große attraktor besteht auf mehreren
zehntausend galaxien hat also eine sehr
große menge an mathe und beeinflusst
somit die anderen matten maßgeblich ganz
alleine für diese bewegung ist da war
wohl doch nicht verantwortlich ihm
gegenüber wurde jetzt eine neue sprache
quelle identifiziert zitat wir fanden
heraus dass unsere milchstraße sich von
einer großen zuvor nicht identifizierten
region niedriger dichte im all weg
bewegt so udo hoffmann von der
hebräischen universität jerusalem dieser
richtigen große attraktor
gegenüberstehende die pole peller würde
dabei gleich viel zur geschwindigkeit
der lokalen gruppen beitragen wie der up
truck der welt da ist also eine ziemlich
leere region im universum dafür
verantwortlich dass wir auf diesen
großen refraktor zu gestalten werden
wechselhaft der rivella ist die erste
bekannte abstoßung quelle im weltall
und wer viel mehr ist zum aktuellen
zeitpunkt überhaupt nicht bekannt also
das ist schon wirklich was absolut neues
und total spannendes ja und wenn irgend
etwas neues kommt werden wir euch sofort
darüber informieren dass der große
attraktor unsere milchstraße anzieht ist
ja schon seltsam und dass der dieb eller
sie auch noch zum ab
faktor hin schiebt das finde ich
wirklich bemerkenswert was passiert
eigentlich das aus wenn man sowas hört
der denkt man wirklich wir haben echt
noch kaum ahnung über das was da im
universum vor sich geht wenn ihr mehr zu
dem thema erfahren wollten große video
dazu gibt auch hier über den großen
traktoren wasser vor sich geht und
einfach draufklicken dann könnte das wie
gesehen und wenn euch das video gefallen
hat laut gerne einen daumen den hier
nach oben oder unten kostenloses abo
drückt am besten die glocke weil dann
verpackt er wirklich kein video und
dafür hier klicken übrigens und was
meint ihr was passiert da draußen lasse
es mir in kommentaren da und ansonsten
würde ich mal sagen bis dann bleibt dran